[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a spanish science
fiction thriller film called the last
days
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in a
post-apocalyptic society after a
mysterious disease spreads across all
the world people become extremely
agoraphobic meaning that they develop a
fear of the outdoors the disease takes
over so quickly that the people who are
outside when it happens die instantly
while the survivors stay wherever they
are it is currently three months after
the disease took over and a cure has
still not been found the world has
collapsed as people stopped coming out
of their houses
an office worker named mark was at work
when the pandemic took over ever since
then he has not been able to return home
to his wife julia at the beginning of
the movie mark scavenges through his
office building for food alongside him
his co-workers are busy going about
their day as they have for several
months now he tries to use the phone but
as expected it doesn't work a view of
the city through the window shows us the
destruction caused by the pandemic mark
looks at the empty streets while eating
a piece of bread his colleague asks him
to come downstairs because it is his
turn to work for the past month they
have been making a tunnel that they can
use to go places since they cannot walk
outside as mark hits the wall he creates
a hole in it and finds out that the
other end meets a subway tunnel later
everyone is being given rationed food
supplies while waiting in line mark sees
his former boss enrique hiding a gps in
his pocket when he asks him what the gps
is for enrique dismisses the matter a
flashback reveals that before the
pandemic mark was working as a computer
engineer one day enrique calls him into
the office and asks him about a deadline
that mark had missed earlier he
threatens mark with possible termination
from the job if he isn't efficient
enough the next time mark works overtime
that night and ignores the calls from
his wife julia he returns home late to
see julia has already had dinner the
couple talks about their plan to have a
baby soon mark doesn't want to rush the
subject while he is having trouble at
work but julia is impatient they have
had several arguments about the matter
in the past
at night mark cannot fall asleep so he
watches the news there's a story about a
16 year old teen who commits suicide
after staying inside his house for more
than six months he had severe
agoraphobia but his father didn't
understand or believe him which led him
to commit suicide the following day in
the office everyone discusses the teen's
tragic death mark notices that one of
his colleagues rovira is wearing the
same clothes that he did for the last
few days it is almost as if he hasn't
returned home at the time mark didn't
understand what rovira's problem was but
looking back at it now he was one of the
first people to get infected by the
disease in the present mark and enrique
are in enrique's office secretly
discussing the gps since the phone's gps
has stopped working mark needs the
device to reach his apartment enrique
requests mark not tell the others about
the device or else they will probably
steal it in the time of crisis mark
reveals that he has stolen supplies
formerly owned by rivera using both of
their tools they can partner up and help
each other reach their destinations
enrique also needs help in going to via
olympia but he doesn't specify his
reasons enrique is initially dismissive
of mark's idea and declines partnering
with him but mark blackmails him into
helping him search for julia the two set
out into the subway system and start
their journey some hours later they
reach the subway station which has now
become home to hundreds of people all of
a sudden a pickpocket snatches enrique's
bag full of supplies and runs away they
chase after him and reach a secluded
area with the pickpocket's gang members
the thugs make the two kneel down
wanting to steal all of their supplies
fortunately for enrique and mark the
power goes out right on time and they
attack the group of thugs in the fight
enrique kills their leader although
worried that enrique will continue
without him mark is relieved to find
that he is willing to continue their
partnership another flashback then shows
us mark getting ready to go to the
office unaware of what is coming on his
way there he enters his neighbor's home
which is filled with trash that seems to
have accumulated over the course of
months it is clear that he has also been
infected but has no clue what is going
on
at work the officials find out that
rivera has been living in his office for
several weeks they kick him out of the
building as he begs for his life people
think he is being too dramatic but as
soon as he is taken outdoors he gets a
seizure and dies following that mark
goes through his belongings and sees
that rivera has accumulated food and
other supplies at night mark tells julia
that something is happening around them
that they are not aware of yet the
incidents bother mark but he doesn't
know what he can do about them julia
hugs him but believes that he is
worrying for no reason they make love
before going to sleep
back in the present mark wakes up
dreaming of her he gets worried when he
sees no one around but is relieved when
enrique approaches him moments later the
two continue their journey through the
subway tunnel mark inquires why enrique
wants to go to via olympia but he again
dismisses the conversation he has also
been collecting seeds of several fruits
throughout the journey which mark thinks
is weird after walking for some miles
they find the opening to the sewer
system they jump into the sewer and use
the gps to get to the building that mark
lived in to get out of the sewer they
will have to blow up a gas cylinder and
make a hole through the ground they miss
the first two tries but are eventually
able to create the explosion mark
finally gets to his room but sees that
it is occupied by a strange man at first
he thinks that the man has abducted his
wife but it turns out that he and his
family were working in the building when
they got infected they couldn't return
home so they took shelter in his
apartment on being asked about julia
they claim that the apartment was empty
when they came in enrique looks around
the kitchen and finds that the family
has caught birds for food he also
collects corn kernels and puts them
inside the bag with the other seeds
meanwhile mark finds a hospital paper
with julia's ultrasound report in it it
is then revealed that she was pregnant
when they last met we are shown yet
another flashback where mark and julia
are watching the news about the disease
spreading at an exponential rate
the condition is now known as the panic
and several people have already died
because of it julia brings up the topic
of having children and they yet again
get into an argument while walking to
work mark notices the streets and the
train are emptier than usual people at
work are also listening to the news
where the experts claim the cause of the
panic is just mass hysteria mark feels
guilty for arguing with julia but when
he calls her friend andrea picks up the
phone wanting to talk to julia he leaves
to go home however as soon as he steps
outside he falls to the ground panicking
mark has also been infected by the
disease using his plot armor he somehow
manages to drag himself inside the
building
back in the present it suddenly starts
to rain enrique and mark collect water
with the help of a curtain and a bucket
everyone in the apartment does the same
as well at night the two collect as many
supplies as they can and leave for their
next destination mark wants to go to the
mall that julia used to work in but
enrique says that they're going to via
olympia next since they have reached his
apartment building he no longer wants to
accompany mark they get into a fist
fight which ends almost immediately
after they accidentally break the
flashlight enrique then reveals that he
wants to go to the hospital that his
father is in after finding him he
promises to give the gps to mark so he
accepts the deal the two continue the
journey and end up in an abandoned
church at the end of the night they find
a lighter and use it to light a fire
hoping to have a cozy night however
their plan is ruined when they are
attacked by a wild bear it attacks
enrique and is about to maul him to
death but mark manages to kill it at the
last second following that they cook the
bear's flesh and devour it as they eat
they talk about their lives before the
pandemic it turns out enrique's only
family is his father who he loves dearly
mark accuses enrique of not paying
attention to his flashback sequences as
they get to know more about each other
they start to bond the following day
they continue the journey through the
sewers to the hospital on their way they
meet another group of survivors who
claim that they have heard rumors about
the hospital being burned to the ground
enrique freaks out and runs to the top
of a building there through a glass
window he sees that the hospital has in
fact burned since his father was
paralyzed and was on the fifth floor he
loses all hope of his survival with no
one to love or to look after enrique
loses the will to live and tries to jump
from the window but mark saves him
enrique now wants mark to continue
looking for julia on his own he even
hands the man his bag of seeds saying
that his child will need them in the
future after an emotional goodbye they
part ways and mark makes his way to the
mall that julia worked in he reaches the
mall without much problem and finds
several dead bodies lying on the ground
people there seem to have fought for
their lives he enters the shop that
julia worked in only to find its owner
dead on the floor fortunately for him
julia's friend andrea has written a note
saying that they are at the supermarket
on his way there he meets another group
of survivors they're reluctant to let
him in but they agree to see if someone
named julia is in their group before
they can get back to him however a rival
group attacks them the ensuing fight
causes most of the people from both
sides to die amidst the chaos mark meets
andrea who tells him that julia has gone
to the gynecologist after mark ended the
call that day they try to run away but
andrea is killed by falling debris
following that a man attacks mark and is
about to kill him but enrique arrives at
the right moment and saves him but just
afterwards enrique is stabbed in the
chest he hides his injury from mark and
offers to join him to search for julia
they walk through the tunnel and end up
in an auditorium mark runs to one of the
upper floors of the building and sees
julia in the opposite building through
the window julia also notices him and is
overjoyed mark quickly runs back to tell
enrique about her but finds him bleeding
to death enrique urges him to go find
julia and live his life happily before
passing away now julia and mark are at
the entrance of two opposite buildings
mark takes the chance and runs across
the street to meet her his head gets
lighter and his ears start to bleed but
his plot armor prevails and he manages
to get to his wife in the end the two
finally reunite and look at each other
with tears of joy some months later
julia gives birth to a healthy boy they
use the seeds that enrique had given
mark to create a greenhouse as their kid
grows up he takes his first step into
the outside world proving that he is
immune to agoraphobia
when he is a teenager several other kids
his age come to take him to rebuild
civilization the movie ends as mark and
julia watch their son walk away with his
new group of friends
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching